welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse ended with a gut punch of a
cliffhanger a true well what the hell
now moment setting up the next
installment beyond the spiderverse
currently slated to release March 29
2024. there's a lot to explain with this
movie's take on the spider-verse or I
should say arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse no post-credit scenes so in
this video we're just gonna discuss
where this movie leaves us and what's
coming next spoilers ahead also I broke
down new details of 2018's into the
spider-verse over on the Deep dive
Channel where on Friday I'm hosting a
live breakdown of across the spiderverse
at noon Eastern support me with one of
these Miles Morales Multiverse dive
shirts at nerd riot.shop it's one of my
favorite new shirt designs I'm gonna be
wearing this all the time and thank you
to box suit for sponsoring this video
more on their tasty operines later so in
2023 Spider-Man across the spider-verse
Miles Morales learns that the spider
Society of Miguel O'Hara has excluded
Miles because he is an anomaly that his
spider alchem X spider number 42 Kane
From Another Universe Earth 42 and was
never supposed to bite him according to
Miguel this collider event caused miles
universe as Peter Parker to die it left
Earth 42 without a Spider-Man and it
created the Multiverse consuming villain
the spot in miles's Universe Jonathan
own revealed in this movie to be the
aquabank scientist in the 2018 movie
that Mouse threw a bagel at producing
that hilarious action word of bagel so
Miguel explains the nature of the
spider-verse aka the web of life and
Destiny or in his words spider-verse
it's called the arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse always lose me with that this
web he says is made up of interlocking
nodes of
events critical Rites of Passage for all
spider people which include deaths of
loved ones and sacrificial deaths of
police captains which for Gwen Stacy
would be her father George Stacy and for
miles would be his father Lieutenant
Jeff Morales soon to be Captain Jeff
Morales and Miles as an anomaly disrupts
these Cannon events just by his nature
which we saw in mumbatin when miles
saves Privateer pravachar's girlfriend's
father Captain Singh from The Fallout of
the crumbling alchemex building in that
universe so Miguel and his Society
trapped villainous anomalies from the
Multiverse of these amber colored shells
including a live action Cameo by Donald
Glover as an alternate universe Aaron
Davis Prowler remember Glover played
Aaron Davis in 2017 Spider-Man
Homecoming in the MCU now he wasn't
necessarily Prowler yet at that time and
he also cameo'd in 2018's into the
spider-verse on Aaron Davis's TV from an
episode of NBC's Community when as the
character Troy he wore Spider-Man PJs
Donald Glover AKA Childish Gambino
voicemails Morales and the Ultimate
Spider-Man animated series so Miguel
tries to encase miles for just a few
days to let miles father Jeff die back
on Earth 1610 because we know the spot
is targeting him but miles is able to
use his electricity powers to explode
out of the energy field and he flees all
the spider people in the HQ he lures
everyone on a chase on the high-speed
rail train of Nueva York then he fries
Miguel's techno organic suit and leaps
back down to the lab where he uses the
machine to cocoon him in a shell that
will send him back to his home reality
based on the DNA of the spider that bit
him so that he could save his father
Miguel does the same to Gwen Stacy
sending her back to Earth 65 with no
Multiverse Gadget so she's not able to
help miles bringing us to the Final Act
where things get really eerie miles
dashes home through the rain he passes
Reflections at spider ham Penny Parker
and Spider-Man Noir his friends in the
2018 film but this red and green tinted
world just looks a little off compared
to the Brooklyn he left behind now when
you're watching your favorite movies and
shows they've got your eyes and ears
covered but what about your other senses
for that you need a snack and if you
want snacks that are as immersive and
transformative as a big Blockbuster film
you want boxu boxu is a premium Japanese
snack box that works with family
businesses all over Japan to deliver a
new theme of authentic Japanese snacks
every month beyond the tasty treat each
box who comes with a booklet that
teaches you all about the theme and
where the snacks come from this month's
theme is midori's Summer and I'm
learning the word Casa which is umbrella
now your first box is going to be
Seasons of Japan and after that you
receive a new theme every month like
this one Midori summer it's packed with
a bunch of green snacks to celebrate the
start of the Lush rainy season in Japan
now let's see what to eat
I am going to try this mini AWA akoshi
snack it's a crunchy Airy puffed rice
snack
oh
I like it it's got Ginger it's got
Sesame this is awesome another great
thing about box soup is that when you
fall in love with the snack just like I
did you can stock up on your favorites
through baksu Boutique both I in the new
Rockstar's office have been receiving
these boxes for ages we love them they
also make a stellar gift for the food or
travel lover in your life so if you want
to try baksu and support the channel
click the link in the description and
use code rockstars to get 15 off your
order meanwhile Miguel leads a search
party of Jessica Drew and Ben Reilly to
Earth 1610 to stop miles and to let Jeff
die and defeat the spot When Stacy
meanwhile back in Earth 65 makes peace
with her dad George who decided to
resign from the police force and
therefore not be a captain and he gives
her a different Gadget designed by Hobie
Brown that Gwen's able to use to go to
1610 to help miles so Miles has gone
home with a little detail in this
bedroom boxing gloves now hanging from
the doorknob this is a room of a miles
who's still working the bag so my house
tells his mother Rio that he's
Spider-Man and we think win is listening
outside but Rio doesn't know who
Spider-Man is for a second we think it's
a joke that Rio might just not be caught
up on current events but no no know like
the classic Silence of the lamps fake
out where Glory Starling is going to one
home while the FBI is raiding a
different home Gwen is actually outside
a different location in a different
Universe miles empty bedroom in 1610
meanwhile miles realizes he is not in
his home universe that machine back in
Nueva York was based on the DNA of the
spider that bit him which was not from
1610 it was from Earth 42 a universe
with no Spider-Man in this universe
uncle Aaron is still alive he says hey
calling back his shoulder move advice
from the first movie and he asked Smiles
why he took his braids out so Aaron a
criminal has been giving Rio to help her
make ends meet and it's taken miles
under his wing they go to the roof and
they see the memorial mural is not
apparent but of miles's Father Jeff
Morales Jeff is dead in this universe
miles gets knocked out and he wakes up
tied to Aaron's punching bag in his
apartment the one that Miles and Aaron
worked out with in the 2018 film and the
one that Miles tied Peter B Parker too
Aaron now reveals that he is not the
prowler someone else's and a younger
Prowler steps forward and unmasks
himself it's the face of Miles his hair
is bright rated the credits identify
this as miles G Morales he's voiced by
Gerald Jerome our Mile's shocked face is
lit by red on one side blue on the other
but in the middle those two colors mixed
Prowler purple a color that not to get
too nerdy about this does not exist in
the normal spectrum of light because in
the spectrum of all visible light by the
human eye blue is on one side red is at
the other end our rods and cones just
kind of mix them together in our heads
that's why purple is often associated
with villains in these movies because
it's just not from this world so our
miles says if I don't get home our dad
is going to die but Prowler corrects
you're dead our miles bags please you
have to let me go the prowler says why
would I do that and he clenches his
armored Fist and presses the punching
bag right beside miles's face so the
film ends with the spot closing in on
miles's Father Jeff back in 1610 but we
hear this wild drum solo taking us back
to the opening image of the movie Gwen
Stacy's drumming with her band The Mary
Janes remember this movie began with
Gwen Stacy leaving her band and now she
says she found a new band the combined
forces of herself Gwen Stacey Peter B
Parker hooby Brown Spider-Man Noir pity
Parker inspired Abraham encores to
rescue and avenge miles end of movie no
post-credits scene see you next year for
Beyond spiderverse but how do any of
them untangle this mess well you could
say miles dad might just be able to go
the George Stacy route and resign from
the pdny but I don't know that seems
like a technicality and not really be
able to undo the anomaly of Miles
existence as the Spider-Man of course
it's also possible that Miguel's
interpretation of the rules of the web
in life and Destiny are not sacrosanct
and that rather than Miles being the
exception the anomaly the mistake the
spider-verse might be stronger if more
spider people were bitten by spiders
from other dimensions because it would
make them responsible not just for their
homes but other neighboring universes
one thing we've learned about these
movies is that sometimes folks just have
to live in multiple Worlds at once and
so maybe by defeating Prowler miles in
the next movie the solution could be to
save him by getting him bitten by a
radioactive spider from Another Universe
And since this movie established
spider-verse Canon events as Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker mourning the death
of Captain Stacy from the 2012 Amazing
Spider-Man film and Tobin McGuire and
Peter Parker greeting Cliff Robertson
Uncle Ben's death in that movie two
universes as we know are linked to the
MCU by Spider-Man no way home in the
spot in this movie visited Mrs Chen from
Venom a universe this movie labels Earth
688 and we also of course got a
live-action MCU actor Donald Glover in
an animated world it's just inevitable
that beyond the spider-verse is going to
leave us with a live-action Miles
Morales who can exist in the MCU now my
Easter egg breakdown of this film is
coming this weekend on the main new
roster's Channel with more videos and
explanations to come beyond that
subscribe to the Deep dive though for
deeper analyzes including my live
breakdown of this movie Friday noon
Eastern and grab a miles Multiverse dive
shirt at nerd riot.shop follow me on
Instagram Twitter eavos following
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you